é com essa apresentação
eu já fui
boa tarde a todos boa tarde a todos em
especial por tarde os amiguinhos aqui
presente
vocês não têm noção da emoção que dá
violentos sentados aqui vocês não têm
noção da alegria que eu tô aqui em vê
los aqui de entrada e partilhar desse
momento com vocês
é bom demais você sabe que a pergunta
que norteia excited é o que nos faz
universidade
na primeira no primeiro momento em que
olhei essa pergunta o que nos faz
universidade
a primeira resposta que me veio à cabeça
foi somos todos universidade
eu preciso dar a você um pouco mais de
ferramentas para que você possa entender
porque de imediato eu pensei na frase
somos todos universidade mas para isso é
preciso contar uma breve história venha
comigo eu venho de uma cidade em que não
havia uma tradição muito grande de
universitários estudantes universitários
não aparecem lá assim em grande
quantidade
é a minha mãe fez ensino superior à
minha mãe fez jornalismo federal
fluminense mas como não exercia a
profissão esse assunto não era um
assunto muito comentado em casa quando
eu fiz a 15 anos de idade um time
apresentou a idéia de um cursinho quando
fez 16
eu fui fazer esse cursinho e lá eu
conheci um mestre tom até hoje um dos
grandes mestres que atravessaram o
caminho seu nome assis até hoje dá aula
aos 17 o pisei à universidade pela
primeira vez e já pisei lá pra fazer
minha matrícula e tudo absolutamente
tudo ali me encantava as paredes num
cantavam a estrutura me encantava os
colegas de classe os professores os
textos os livros que eu precisava ali em
pé na livraria porque não tinha grana
pra pra comprá los
cada aula particular que jogava para
poder financiar a xérox financiar a
passagem tudo aquilo me dava um tesão
enorme
a possibilidade está vivendo dentro de
uma universidade participando dos seus
movimentos
me dá uma alegria muito muito grande aos
18 comecei a trabalhar numa
multinacional e foi aí que eu percebi
que não era exatamente aquilo que eu
queria fazer administração de empresas
na universidade federal fluminense
trabalhava numa multinacional
isso pra você pode não parecer muito mas
pra gente era muita coisa mas você sabe
que não era aquilo exatamente o que eu
queria eu olhava para as paredes do
escritório olhava para meus colegas de
profissão e dizia não é isso não é
exatamente onde eu tenho que está um dia
então depois de um pouco a angústia eu
fui até o meu chefe disse olha eu estou
indo embora
ele disse vítor você tem certeza que é
isso que tem que fazer disse claro que
não é só tem 19 anos mas em algum
momento tiver que fazer isso este
momento tem que ser agora
ele gentilmente me demitiu que me
permitiu ganhar uma graninha
eu comprei algumas cadeiras de braço com
os ventiladores de teto e comecei a dar
aula na minha casa
naquele primeiro ano eu tive três
estudantes
lá se vão 20 anos
nos últimos anos a gente tem uma média
de 150 aprovações 150 aprovações por ano
em todas as carreiras que vocês possam
imaginar ea gente só conta as
universidades públicas
então estamos falando de direito
medicina engenharia e nutrição
fisioterapia
exatamente por isso que somos todos
universidade impactava tanto porque a
minha mais da metade da minha vida eu
dediquei à universidade
mais da metade da minha vida eu me
dediquei a fazer com que mais e mais
estudantes pudessem ingressar na
universidade e ter a experiência de
vivenciar aquilo que eu vivenciei os
muros os colegas
os textos os professores o tesão de
estar lá
e nesse sentido esse é o johnny
o johnny e passou para medicina
ele é um bairro periférico de uma cidade
periférica
você não pode ter idéia do tesão que dá
quando o estudante como estes conseguem
chegar lá amigos pra você que vem de uma
família que a universidade é de praxe
saber de gente que a princípio não
conseguiria estar lá chegar lá é muito
legal
boa parte dos estudantes
eles são os primeiros a entrar numa
universidade daqui algumas gerações
alguém vai dizer tudo começou com o vovô
ele é o vovô somos todos universidade eu
queria te lembrar esse discurso em 2
partes venha comigo
primeiro quando falamos somos a gente
está no verbo ser
e ser pré supõe existir ser no mundo é o
dever do nit ser no mundo é exige enorme
desafio porque a cada passo não sabemos
exatamente para onde estamos indo
a cada passo e precisamos fazer escolhas
da capasul precisamos decidir os rumos
que vamos dar a vida que a nossa ser do
mundo pressupõe um ineditismo enorme
acho graça quando alguém diz olha você
precisa ser inovador
eu digo estou fazendo isso desde as seis
da manhã você nunca viveu o dia 4 de
outubro de 2016 e nunca ter a
oportunidade de vê lo de novo ser no
mundo será a universidade a participar
dela ser universidade integrar se a ela
ser a universidade é dedicar-se enquanto
você estiver ali se universidade para
muitos é um sonho mas pra vocês e boa
parte de nossos presentes aqui já é uma
realidade
hoje boa parte dos meus amores alunos
estudantes estão ávidos por entrar lá
mas a gente já está lá o nosso somos
traz mais desafios porque ao falarmos
somos estamos no verbo do presente eo
presente não é hoje presente ao agora
hoje mesmo eu acordei hoje mesmo de
início essa palestra o presente é o
tecido sobre o qual rascunho
mas a nossa vida o presente a linha
tênue que separa o passado do futuro
a minha avó dizia vitinho aproveite aqui
aqui porque não existe aqui
lá o presente é tudo o que temos amigos
e é nele que a gente pode construir
aquilo que a gente quer
somos todos universidade é nesse
presente que a gente vai construir andré
comte-sponville filósofo francês tem um
livro cujo título é felicidade
desesperadamente onde ele propõe uma
felicidade sem esperança
e nesse momento você diz é como seria
possível uma felicidade sem esperança
pois é quem espera ainda não tem quem
espera o ônibus quem tem esperança de
pegar o ônibus não têm o ônibus que têm
esperança de encontrar o grande amor
ainda não encontrou o grande amor
quem tem esperança de ser feliz ainda
não é feliz
eu proponho pra gente uma universidade
desesperada uma universidade
desesperadamente não é uma universidade
do futuro é uma universidade do ac e do
agora uma universidade que faremos no
contato nas conexões uma universidade
que faremos lado a lado que faremos
juntos e por isso esse verbo está no
plural porque grita em nós uma
necessidade uma pluralidade mais uma
pluralidade que respeite as
singularidade e avós não gostaria de ver
gente batendo panela enquanto o outro
fala é o diálogo
platão escreve dezenas de diálogos e nos
diz que o ensino eo aprendizado se faz
no diálogo na conversa na escuta atenta
por isso o verbo no plural
começamos aos poucos sim preocupação em
quantidade sem preocupação em distância
uma conexão com um amigo do lado uma
conexão com um amigo da frente à escuta
atenta é clichê eu sei mas são dois
ouvidos e uma boca
talvez devêssemos ouvir duas vezes mais
do que a gente fala e escuta atenta para
o outro
quando vamos para a palavra universidade
eu me remeto a idéia de um universo que
me remeto a idéia de universal e vou
recuperar aqui a definição de uma
criança sobre o que é o universo
ele tem 12 anos a definição é genial
o universo é a casa das estrelas venha
comigo nessa reflexão
primeiro a gente precisa diferenciar o
que é casa do que lá em casa é um monte
de gente reunida em baixo do mesmo teto
lá é gente reunida sob o mesmo teto
dispostas a se entenderem como fazer mas
claro é preciso que haja de aula que
ensinam monólogos consecutivos monólogo
com o executivo é jogo de tênis você
fica feliz quando o outro perde
o monólogo consecutivo é duas pessoas
conversando assim já viu um fala pra
galera aí pela graça de deus em algum
momento ele tem que parar para respirar
é a vez do outro e ninguém se ouve são
monólogos consecutivos você fica feliz
quando o outro perde diálogo e frescobol
você fica feliz quando o outro acerto de
aula quando você fala e outro ouvir o
outro houve a atenção e falar caramba eu
não tinha pensado assim mas se a gente
pensasse assim e devolve a bola e você
pega a bola é tem razão mas se
pensássemos assim
vejam a diferença entre monólogo
consecutivo e diálogo
a universidade é o lugar do diálogo
a universidade é o lugar da troca da
conversa do bate papo
teremos um dia inteiro aqui para
aproveitar isso não desperdicem essa
oportunidade criar laços
ter conexões é pra isso que temos longos
braços é prazo é para isso que temos
lagos é que o beijo nada em nosso plano
a violência
tudo o que é violência no homem
artifício é a arma é garra a gente não
tenha pegada da violência a gente não
tenha mandíbula da violência tudo em nós
lama pela paz
tudo em nós clama pela escuta atenta ao
outro
a universidade pode ser sim o ar
na medida que a universidade for esse
lugar de encontro de troca de afetos
esse lugar onde a gente possa de a louca
e aí você pode perguntar professor vitor
então ao dialogarmos conseguiremos
sempre um consenso
eu não é claro que não
mas aí está a beleza da diferença
amar o outro por o que ele tem de igual
amigos não é amor é narcisismo é amar o
próprio espelho amar quem ama pensando
exatamente como você que mérito isso a
universo é a casa das estrelas
somos estrelas e nesse momento você vai
dizer então pegou pesado na metáfora
somos estrelas claro
recorremos a caetano veloso que nos diz
somos feitos para brilhar e não para
morrer de fome
todas as vezes que vimos um desenho
animado em que alguém tem uma ideia
genial aparece uma lâmpada zinha um dia
me disseram que as nuvens não eram de
algodão sem querer eles me deram as
chaves que abrem essa prisão e tudo
ficou tão claro um intervalo na
escuridão
a universidade é o lugar que pode
oferecer um intervalo na escuridão
nada mais triste de uma vir acompanhada
de conhecimento
a pequena nada porque não consegue
vislumbrar o novo eo pia é a causa de
todo o nosso sofrimento
sofremos porque não somos capazes de ver
além
longe o conhecimento nos permite essa
possibilidade
vislumbra sim a universidade pode ser
lugar de gente brilhante sim a
universidade pode ser lugar de nos fazer
brilhar
só por um instante nenhum comigo só por
um instante nenhum comigo
a aula começa às 9 horas e 86 já estamos
lá estudantes com tesão de aprender
professores com tesão de ensinar sem
negociação sem brincadeiras no sentido
de para fora daquilo que a gente quer
pense nisso em uma sala de aula todos
dispostos a aprender estudantes
dispostos a dar o máximo de si
professores dispostos a dar o máximo de
si todos nós empenhados dedicados
esforçados
agora pense nisso em duas aulas três
salas pensem isso numa universidade
inteira amigo só por um instante sem o
luxo de pensar nisso numa nação
eu e você e acordando para sermos o
melhor que a gente pode ser porque somos
universais e temos com ele e temos para
com ele esse universo compromisso um
lixo que produzimos aqui não é um lixo
do rio de janeiro não é um lixo do
brasil não é um lixo da américa é um
lixo mundial porque somos muito maiores
do que nos parece eu não sou um cidadão
do rio de janeiro
eu não sou um cidadão do brasil não sou
um cidadão da américa eu sou um cidadão
do planeta terra e tenho para com ele
compromisso
momento você pode se perguntar beleza
vital
tudo muito bonito mas por onde a gente
começa aqui e agora
como dizia a vovó vitinho aproveite aqui
aqui porque não existe aqui o meu
convite é para agora o meu convite para
a felicidade desesperada para a
universidade desesperada com o convite
para uma vida que acontece aqui e agora
nas palavras de woody allen a realidade
é dura mas é nela que a gente como um
bom bife com fritas
a minha proposta é esqueçam os números
esqueçam as distâncias comecem por quem
está do seu lado o seu lado tem uma
pessoa que sofre tanto quanto você se
angustia se entristece
do seu lado a pessoa que se emociona com
o pôr do sol não sei se você sabe que um
dia foi tomar banho um pouco mais tarde
do que devia e chorou sem saber
exatamente porque alguém teve uma noite
insone por uma saudade por um amor que
não teve um amor que perdeu
somos feitos muito mais de coisas que
nos unem de coisas que nos separam
somos humanos
todos nós demandamos todos nós
precisamos do outro
lá no curso em um hino
esse nuvem de chico buarque venha comigo
juntos somos fortes somos flechas somos
arco todos nós no mesmo barco não há
nada a temer
ao meu lado a um amigo que é preciso
proteger todos juntos somos fortes
porque sozinhos não somos nada somos
arco e flecha porque ora precisamos de
alguém que nos lança o infinito hora
estaremos dispostos a avançar pessoas no
infinito todos nós no mesmo barco não há
nada a temer porque somos humanos e
precisamos todos uns dos outros
precisamos aprender a ser humano
aprender a viver e faremos isso de forma
coletiva acontecer mas o universo só
porque sendo universais
somos todos universidade senhoras e
senhoritas foi um prazer inefável estar
na presença de vocês
desejo sucesso
[Aplausos]